[Music]
sky villa dawson its high-rise high
density public housing and the
development is also in a very mature
hdvs state the Queenstown which has a
lot of history and heritage it is
project specially commissioned to look
at the future of housing in Singapore
one of the objectives that we want to
achieve is creating communities and
communities form when we start to create
spaces that capture the daily routines
that people are doing every day the sky
village will be one of the community
spaces that we've created for sky deal
is that an enhance community bonding we
also created this landscape Park by
keeping or preserving the existing rain
trees along Margaret Drive
there's also playgrounds and fitness
corners variety is our second design
objective for this development and the
Union layout is one of those areas that
we look into we created being free
interiors and there will be seeds there
will be outdoor furniture that people
can just sit down or have a chat with
the neighbors so these are all social
life that can happen during the daily
routes that we want to capture in the
spaces we created
we hope the users will be the one to
appreciate to be able to see what we see
to enjoy what we create in urban project
such as this one